[Music]
[Applause]
uh Charles Barkley kind enough to join
us kind enough to leave town when we get
out there to Arizona is that on purpose
that you didn't want to at least give me
the code to your house so I can go to
the compound and play with your toys
you know Dan we don't let many people in
my neighborhood I'm not gonna lie you
know it's just really unfortunate I hate
I'm not going to be there I'm actually
not going to be there the entire time
and that's really unfortunate
um but I got to go to Attila forces golf
tournament
and I got to shoot some commercials uh
so unfortunately I will not be in town
okay uh I'm gonna miss you Dan because I
wanted you to come hang out at the house
I I want it man did you how much weight
have you lost
I've lost about 60 pounds I'm getting in
shape Dan my doctor got on my ass he
said you see a lot of fat young people
you don't see no fat old people because
they're all dead so he told me to get it
together how are you doing it
uh I got a great doctor her name is
Jacqueline Pearson she's got me on this
uh realistic it's just some some type of
drug to be honest with you
um I don't want people whining and
complaining but I'm taking some drug I
take a shot every week got about two
more weeks ago I've been on it for like
three months but um things are going
great good uh I I want to have you have
your Super Bowl bet did you place it
oh Eagles all the way brother Eagles all
the way okay you don't care the uh the
point spread you you've got them winning
outright
uh uh I think they're gonna win no
matter what you know but you know
they've been my team for a long time
and uh man they've been the best team
all year to be honest with you yeah
and uh and then you know Jalen hurts uh
do you know him at all
I know I'm a little bit uh we did a
thing back when Auburn beat him beat up
beat him uh when he was at the
University of Alabama wait I shouldn't
say at the Alabama University he's a
great kid
shout out to him and whoever's been to
work man he's really improved and he's
published as a quarterback
I cannot wait for the Super Bowl you
know I got a lot of love for Travis
Kelsey but man I'm I'm just pulling for
my Eagles
it feels like every night somebody's
getting 50 points in the NBA where it
used to be or 60. back in the mid 90s
when I was doing SportsCenter if you got
50 you were leading SportsCenter now
it's just like oh you only got 50 did
you get a triple double like what do you
think is the biggest reason why we're
seeing this scoring explosion
two things lack of defense and the
three-point shot you know Dan
everybody's playing small ball so
there's no realm protection so if you
have a knight where you're making a
bunch of Threes you're gonna score but
you factor in everybody's playing small
ball now so even if you're not making
threes you're probably number one you're
gonna get a lot more free throws but
also you're gonna get a lot more layups
because everybody
you know they made the they made the
game really it's and I'm not trying to
be the old guy they made it like it's a
three-point shooting contest every night
but then you're gonna file more and like
I say there's no shot blockers in the
game anymore but what would Shaq be in
this you know today's NBA
well see and that's that's actually one
of my biggest problem because
you even got the seven foot dummies out
there shooting threes now
if I'm a big guy
I would love to play in today's game
yeah you're gonna maybe the guy I'm
guarding gonna make some threes which
most big guys ain't gonna make enough
threes to make a difference in the game
but I'm gonna kill them in the paint I'm
gonna do a great job offensive
rebounding and I'm gonna get to the free
throw line a lot
so they've kind of went overboard
shooting the threes but you know listen
you can look at a guy like Joker MB
there's a reason they're dominating they
actually getting their big putts in the
paints and that's why those probably the
two lead Front Runners for MVP because
if you're a big guy man it's so easy now
because number one you got so much more
room to work with because with all the
three-point Shooters you really get to
go one-on-one every time and you're not
gonna stop and beat or the Joker
one-on-one
I think you had 56 in the playoff game
and might have had one three uh uh three
threes two or three threes but how would
you how would you be used in today's NBA
well I'm not going to change my game I'm
gonna be in I'll be in the paint listen
like I say
whoever I'm playing against they're not
gonna make enough threes to offset how
many points I'm gonna score and get my
team in free throw foul trouble
so like I say and like who are they
gonna put on me they can't put one of
them little small ass dudes on me
because I'm gonna just murder him so I
think the trade-off is better for me
like I say what Joel and B Joker what
they're gonna do is for is getting
layups and dunks
uh and getting the other team in foul
trouble what am I gonna do you think I'm
worried about my guy a seven foot guy or
a 16 guy are they gonna make enough
threes to offset me hell no I'm gonna
get my layup and like I say I'm gonna
get more space because they probably
gonna put more three-point Shooters
around me
uh so I I would feel really good about
my game even though I'm a poster I've
got I feel really good about my game if
I play today I guess it's a Michael
Jordan day two three
23.
well I'm pretty I know I'm Michael
Jordan alone time I'm pretty sure every
day
when you got a couple billion dollars
and you were Michael Jordan I'm pretty
damn sure every day is Michael Jordan
day but would you trade your life for
Michael Jordan's life with what he goes
through I mean privacy and all of those
things you live up you're you're a a
person you're a man of the people would
you trade your life for Mike's life
I wouldn't trade my life for anybody's
life you know man I Dan I have exceeded
you know you're growing up in a small
town of a couple thousand people in
Alabama
you're not thinking you're gonna grow up
and be Charles Barkley man I have been
and I'm not trying to be humble or I'm
just so lucky and blessed I mean I can't
believe it then think about it I'm
growing up in the project in a small
town of a couple thousand people
and unfortunately and no I don't I don't
mean that unfortunately man I'll be 60
in a couple weeks and I'm on The Dan
Patrick Show and I'm not just saying
that you're one of the the best to ever
do it growing up in a small town of a
couple thousand people and 60 years
later I'm like wow
I've been honored and blessed to be
Charles Barkley man it's it's been
pretty cool now listen Michael is the
greatest and LeBron and Kobe and Wayne
Gretzky and Federer all these guys are
some of the greatest to ever do it
Serena I don't want to leave her out
but man hey hey as I say so myself
sometimes man you did pretty good yes
you did yes you did are we celebrating
LeBron enough
where I want to say two things I think I
hope people have a great appreciation
for Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
how great
that record is so hopefully that one
thing will come out of this two things
excuse me I apologize number one the
greatness of Kareem having this record
I mean it's incredible but I've said
this before
I think that LeBron James listen
you know this debate first of all I
always think that debate is silly when
guys have no Talent they go on TV and
radio and say my uh Kobe you know they
like to who's the greatest LeBron's been
the greatest at last well Kobe had a
stress when he was the greatest well Tim
Duncan had a stress when he was the
greatest
but I want to appreciate Kareem first
but I've said this before LeBron I think
has the greatest story not just in
basketball history in sports history
we've never had a player because as
great as Kobe and Kevin Garnett
McGrady and all those guys where people
forget they struggled when they came
into the NBA
I've said this before LeBron coming in
at 18. being pretty good from the first
day
I and never really getting in trouble
especially when people are out to get
you in today's social media camera
phones everywhere
I think he's had the greatest sports
story of all time
and it's amazing that he's doing this 20
years later but to be great from day one
or really good from day one and never
get in trouble
I think it's the greatest sports story
of all time
is Charles Barkley the Hall of Famer TNT
inside the NBA better career
accomplishments
LeBron or Tom Brady
Tom Brady
Tom Brady uh I think that it we should
appreciate Tom Brady more you know Dan
I'm gonna explain why
number one you know 10 Super Bowls is
incredible
but the thing that's crazy why I put
football accomplishment ahead of
basketball accomplishments is you know
every game in the NFL is a one game you
out and you're done yeah good point if
you got
Kareem
uh Larry Bird Magic Johnson Kobe LeBron
Michael
you got to you got the best player in
every game you can lose one game you can
lose two games you can actually lose
three games
but to have every game be a game seven
again every game in the NFL is a game
seven yeah no matter how great your
regular season was
to have every game be the end of your
season and for this man to make it to 10
super bowls and win seven
it's it's one of the greatest
accomplishments in history I mean
you know playing against Michael and
like I said I never played really
against LeBron but you've got the best
player
and you can like I said you can lose a
bunch of games but to have every game be
a game seven I think what Tom Brady
accomplished it's it's arguably his
career is unparalleled
I mean I think about it it's great as
Pat Mahomes is think about that it's
great as Pat Mahomes is
if he wins this Super Bowl he's only got
two
he's only got two Dan think about that
and I love Pat
even though I'm going with my Eagles and
I love Travis Kelsey If he if if they
win
that he will only have two he got to get
another handful
if you hung out with Brady at all
I have and he is the most humble cool
goat I've ever been around but what do
you talk about
um
we actually I don't think we talk about
sports
he's just I tell people and you can just
tell Dan like when I heard Teddy brewski
and actually you know we had Von Miller
on men Ernie's podcast yesterday
and we talked about uh Tom and he says
man the craziest thing about Tom
you know I didn't want to like him when
I met him
but he was so like cool and humble I was
like and this is Von Miller one of the
all-time great saying yeah man Tom was
talking to me like I was just like some
guy he had just met on the street and he
was caught kind and and that's the way
when I've been around Tom he's like hey
Chuck how you doing good to see you and
I'm saying to myself
this dude know he Tom Brady
but but man but there are guys who are
like that Chuck you know Jordan was the
same guy off the floor as he was on the
floor guys turn it on and turn it off
and and you know you've seen greatness
that they're able to do that some guys
can't turn it on or off Brady is a very
mild-mannered I've only met two goats
who are like that
that's uh Tom and and Wayne Wayne
Gretzky those are the two goats who like
they're really now listen I love Michael
and tiger but nobody has ever said oh
man they really nice guys
they said that Michael Jordan is the
greatest player ever they said man that
tiger was the greatest golfer ever but
were they never been cleared oh man
they're some nice guys they're really
humble guys
all right but when you're around top and
like I say Tom and Wayne are the two
goats that I'm like oh yo man those
dudes are really nice guys and listen
it's in like
Michael and tiger they just did it
differently
uh but they're both too in my opinion
they're the two ghosts of their sports
but I never heard somebody say man that
Michael the tiger a nice guy so the
words never been spoken
uh well Michigan Arizona and uh if I do
a drive-by you're compound like there's
nobody there who's gonna shoot me will
there be oh there's a guard down there
it is it's okay because I hate listen
no you can't I don't want people come
inside Neighbors coming by saying hey
can I borrow sugar hell no okay go to
the store and get your own damn sugar I
don't want a dad I don't want surprises
I don't want people coming up to my
house okay fair enough we won't we won't
we'll wait till you're there next time I
hate that I'm gonna miss you though Dan
because I really wanted okay I really
want to take you to play golf
I really did yeah because you're now
playing well
I'm playing great uh I you know I like
to say I got to go to Florida for Ally
the forces golf tournament she's the
best her and her husband Joe Joe was a
softball pitcher in his Heyday
um but I then I got to shoot some
commercials but man then you know what
Chuck gonna do leave the me and the boys
I got about 10 or 15 of my friends yeah
we have been going to Vegas for the
Super Bowl for 25 years oh boy
so oh yeah hey Dan you know I feel about
gambling it's a 50 50 chance he's gonna
win or you're gonna lose hey in my mind
that's 50 50. but when you go to Vegas
you visit your money because you helped
build some of those buildings there
yeah you know what but I'm all Hey
listen always go in with the right
attitude I'm gonna get some good cars
this trip I'm gonna get good cars this
trip my luck is going to change
good to talk to you man safe travels
amen
uh you're the best Dan thank you for
having me all right man that's Charles
Barkley